hi there I am Matt I'm an applications
engineer with heartwig and today we are
starting a series on the lathe made by
Akuma um this particular lay that we're
going to be working on is going to be an
lb 3000
ex2 this machine is an myw model that
means that this machine has Milling
that's what the m stands for it has y
AIS on the turret and it also is
equipped with a sub spindle that's what
the W stands
for this particular machine is equipped
with an OSP p300 La control in this
video we're going to be going over the
basic layout on this control going
button by button and what each button
does and what function it
performs the first thing we're going to
be covering are our mode selection keys
that is going to be these Eight Keys up
here the first three are are operation
mode
Keys the first one is auto
operation this is where you're going to
be performing automated operation say
you're running your
program watching your your loads and
your distance to go
next is going to be your manual data
input or
MDI this is where you can manually input
G and M codes to perform specific
machine
operations and third is going to
be your manual key in your manual key is
where you can jog the machine and
perform manual machine operations
the next set of keys are your data
setting mode
Keys the first of the data setting mode
keys are your main operation key this
will always default your screen back to
your main operation screen that displays
your program your distance to go and
additional information in this upper
right hand
corner next is your edit aux
key it can also be thought of as your
file management key in here you can send
and receive programs and do background
edit next is our tool data key inside
here we manage our tool
offsets and manage Tools in here you can
also utilize functions such as tool
school life
management next we have our
parameters inside our parameters key is
a lot of our machine
settings and last is our macman key
inside macman is data
collection alarm
history and productivity information
moving down from our mode selection Keys
we have a standard
keyboard a couple of notes for the
keyboard is you do use the shift
button in conjunction with special
characters the caps lock is also an
important thing to remember the control
shows up here that caps lock is on right
now you can turn it on and
off from there we have our tab selection
buttons that's what these two are you'll
notice that when I hit the tab to the
right this
tab will be
selected next we have page up and page
down these are useful when editing
programs if you want to move through
large chunks of program at a time and
then you have single line up down left
and
right next we have a number
pad along with our mathematical
functions displayed
on and then at the end we have our
backspace key
this is our cancel button also
infamously known as the hot dog
Button next we have right enter
key an important note to know the
difference between backspace and cancel
so if we go to
MDI and we were to
type
M3 back space will delete one
character whereas cancel will remove it
all the enter right button is also
important to note so when you're an MDI
if you were to enter
m03 it puts it in the MDI line and you
have to hit right or enter to put it
into the
buffer next we're going to cover the
function keys and the soft keys
these correlate with each other so they
perform the same operation so if I press
the key on the screen it's the same as
pressing the key the hard button
below the first of the function keys is
going to be your information
button inside your information button is
your pocket manual your pocket manual is
very handy for looking up G&M codes
program format and alarms
if you have an active alarm on the
machine and you press the information
button it'll automatically display that
alarm along with the
description so you have function keys 1
through
8 and then at the end there's a button
that we call the extend key what the
extend key does is display additional
soft key options so if I hit this you're
going to see there's new
selections and you can toggle all the
way through until you get back to where
you
started moving to the lower section of
the panel we're going to start on the
left side
here the first and most important button
that you have is your emergency stop
pressing this will stop all functions of
the and
C below that we have our cycle start
button and then feed
hold moving over this is what we call
our pulse hand wheel section of the
control the top portion is where you
select the axes that you want to move
with the pulse handle
below that is where you select the
increments that you want to move
in the first increment being five thou
per click second is going to be one thou
per click and last is going to be one
tenth per
click it's important to remember that
these functions are only available if we
are in manual mode
next we have our pulse handle onof
button so turning this on and off will
activate this section of the
panel and then below that we have W axis
movement forward and
reverse these two buttons are only
available if your machine is equipped
with an NC tail stock or a subspindle
below that is our CA access control
movement so these buttons are continuous
feed jog
buttons so the center button is your
cais connect so if we hit
this it'll blink until the c-axis on the
machine is
engaged once it's engaged we can
continuously feed our cais
when we're done we'll turn the c-axis
off moving down to the panel below it we
have our continuous feed for our X which
is
here Z
if your machine is equipped with a Y
AIS this button will activate your
y then the corner buttons are your
movement for your y AIS
when you're ready to return your y AIS
to the center position your cut position
or y z you can press this button in the
lower right hand corner and it'll
automatically return to the center
position when it's at the center
position it will light up
when that button is lit up you can turn
the y- AIS back
off the next section of the panel the
first button we're going to see is our
single block button single block allows
a program to only read one line at a
time when in auto
mode the next button is block skip what
that does if that button is activated it
will skip any line of code in your
program that has a forward slash at the
beginning of
it next is dry run dry run allows the
machine to move in Rapid mode when it's
reading feed moves this is useful when
the machine is in machine lock mode
machine lock mode separates the
control from the
NC so if you were to run a program while
the machine is in machine lock you will
see the program being simulated in your
graphics you'll see your program running
on your actual position tab you'll see
the code getting red but the pro machine
itself will not be
moving sometimes if you have a large
program it's handy to use dry run so
you're not waiting for the slower feed
moves next you have individual mode A
and B these two buttons are only
relevant on a machine that has an upper
and a lower turret if you wanted to run
an a turret individually from a b turret
you could select one or the
other next is optional stop
optional stop will stop your program
anytime it reads an
m01 then we have mid Auto
manual mid Auto manual
allows manual machine functions while
being in Auto or MDI mode this can be
very handy when interrupting a program
midcycle
Eco idle
stop this will just put the machine into
a power saving
mode sequence
restart sequence restart is
applicable when you are trying to
restart a program Midway
through next we have this interlock
release button
you will notice that some of these
buttons are white any button that's
white requires you to press interlock
release before pressing that
button it's kind of a dual safety
feature then we have all coolant
off it'll shut down all coolant
functions of the machine that currently
on the light button will shut the light
off in the machine if you want to shut
the light
off coolant on will restart the coolant
after you've shut it
off the air blow button will generally
blow air out of the line that is above
the
spindle then we have this machine
operation button
this is all the auxiliary functions of
the
machine next we have our tool index plus
or
minus this button will index your turret
in the
positive or negative Direction
keep in mind you can only index your
turret if you're at the X limit of the
machine that is indicated when there is
a green light next to the x axis on your
distance to go
display the last two buttons to cover if
your machine is equipped with an auto
door then this button will open your
door and this button will'll close
it this here is our feed and Rapid
override on a p300 it is standard that
your feed and Rapid override are
combined into one
knob as we move over on the control
you'll see a light
here since this model is equipped with a
uh main spindle and a sub spindle we can
see that our main spindle is currently
selected when the main spindle is
selected any of these
buttons that are down here are going to
be
impacted by the spindle that is
currently
selected the first button we have is
spindle stop which will stop the spindle
if it's
rotating the next button we have is
spindle clamp
this is equivalent to a c-axis break
it'll stop the spindle from being able
to be
rotated next we have spindle
counterclockwise and spindle
clockwise if your machine is in manual
mode these will start your spindle in
whichever direction you select
next we have a jog button the jog button
will rotate the spindle Without The
Machine being in c-axis mode it'll
rotate it continuously until you stop
pressing
it the next button we have is a spindle
index button this will
Orient your main spindle
which is the equivalent to an
m19 the two lights below that are going
to indicate if your spindle one is in a
clamped or unclamped
state and then the knob below this is
your spindle speed override
if we move over to the right you can see
we have a spindle 2 with the similar
indicating
lights telling us if it's in a clamped
or unclamped
state along with a spindle over right if
your machine has Milling it will have a
panel that looks like
this
similarly clockwise and counterclockwise
will turn your Milling spindle
on and the stop button will stop
it it's important to note that to
utilize the jog
function your cais has to be active so
we can turn our c-axis
on with our c-axis active we can jog our
Milling spindle similarly
that we could to our turning
spindle the up and down
arrow are
your spindle speed override for your
Milling
spindle if your machine has a sub
spindle this is the button you push when
in manual mode to select spindle
2 when you press it you can see that
spindle 2 light is lit up here also
second spindle is displayed on the
screen if you're on a machine that has
multiple turrets like an A and A B
turret you will see an a
turret here and a b turret here and you
will select them similarly to spindle
one and two
next is our reset
button this will reset the machine to
normal operations if it's in an alarm
State this button is your control on
button it turns the machine on when the
main power is
on also if EOP is
depressed and you need to restart the
machine to normal
operation you press control on to
restart
it below that is your control off
button you turn this off and this will
power down your control before shutting
off the main power on the
machine next we have an NC panel key
this will lock out functions of the
machine based upon where it's set
depending on whether you have setup or
operators running the
machine at the bottom here we have our
door interlock key if this is turned to
the off position it will inhibit all
machine movement while the door is
open thanks for watching